[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
copycat Rezept wir machen nämlich das
Essen wie bei halal Geist wir waren ja
in New York und halalgeist ist so ein
leckeres street food so unscheinbar sind
so ganz kleine was sind eigentlich wie
heißt du machen Sie
dieses food Trucks genau food Trucks und
ich habe Leute ich habe selten so was
leckeres gegessen als street food boah
ich kann ihn halt verstehen
auf diese Bank auf der wir saßen und wir
einfach dieses leckere Essen inhaliert
haben was ist das überhaupt das ist ein
richtig lecker gewürztes Hähnchen so ein
bisschen pult-style und so machen wir
das heute auch aber Pult schicken dauert
immer sehr sehr lange man muss es zwei
Stunden zwei Stunden im Ofen garen ich
zeige euch heute einen einfach und
schnelle Variante und leckere gewürzreis
und was ganz besonders ist ist die White
Source und da könnte ich mich richtig
reinlegen die mache ich heute auch ich
starte jetzt erstmal mit dem abonnieren
ich schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen Mengenangaben unten in die
Infobox einfach unterm Titel aufklappen
screenshotten einkaufen und Nachmachen
so ich habe jetzt hier mein Hähnchen ich
mache jetzt von der Personenanzahl her
für hamzon mich also für zwei Personen
schreibt euch aber unten rein ähm die
Mengenangaben für vier Personen weil ich
finde das ist gängiger dann können das
ja trotzdem noch halbieren aber es ist
halt ja super gängig für vier Portion
alles aufzuschreiben hier kommt jetzt
erstmal Olivenöl drauf zum Marinieren da
habe ich jetzt hier schon meine Gewürze
einfach schon mal abgemessen das gebe
ich mit dazu und Pfeffer immer frisch
aus der Mühle das schmeckt einfach viel
besser so was ich da jetzt auch noch
rein gebe ist Koriander Petersilie werde
ich meinen hacken und die Knoblauchzehe
und dann wird das schön mariniert und
wenn ihr Zeit habt lasst ihr das ähm ein
paar Stunden marinieren ihr könnt auch
am Vortag machen wenn ihr keine Zeit
habt dann ist auch eine halbe Stunde
okay
[Musik]
während unser Hähnchen mariniert nutze
ich die Zwischenzeit und mache schon mal
den Reis ich benutze Basmati
Langkornreis den ich vorab gut ausspülen
einfach damit die Stärke ausgespült wird
das Wasser wird dann von sehr sehr trüb
zu etwas klarer also es wird nie ganz
klar aber so dass zumindest die Stärke
ausgespült ist und der reißt nicht mehr
klebt und jetzt gebe ich hier in meinen
Topf habe ich hier schon erwärmt ein
bisschen Öl aber auch brutal ist ein
guter Geschmacksträger nicht zu heiß den
Topf damit die Butter nicht anbrennt ich
habe jetzt hier gerade so Stufe 7 von 9
das ist hier so ein bisschen schmelzen
und dann wird der Reis darin geröstet
ihr könnt auch vorab schon mal die
Gewürze mit dazu geben das Salz dann
aber nicht ihr könnt aber auch danach
dazu geben das ist ganz entspannt also
einfach den Rest da so ein bisschen
anrösten so 2 Minuten und dann kommen
die Gewürze mit rein und wird das Ganze
wird mit Wasser aufgegossen
[Musik]
so es geht weiter mit dem Hähnchen ich
habe kurz Plätze getauscht mein Reis ist
jetzt rüber gewandert und ich habe hier
meine Grillpfanne bei halalgeist wird
das Fleisch auch gegrillt natürlich
nicht in der Pfanne aber wir wollen ja
nicht den langen Weg über den Backofen
gehen und wir haben jetzt auch oder kann
es gar nicht die Möglichkeit so zu
grillen die Grillpfanne ist die perfekte
Alternative vor allem wenn ihr da auch
ein passenden Deckel zu habt ich
verlinke euch meine mal in die Infobox
und da gebe ich jetzt mein
Hähnchenfleisch rein dadurch das wäre
jetzt hier schon ähm Öl haben müssen wir
jetzt auch erstmal kein weiteres Öl in
die Pfanne geben es werden ihr merkt
dass es zu wenig dann könnt ihr
natürlich ein bisschen Öl noch mit
dazugeben und dann braten wir das Schaf
von beiden Seiten an
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt von beiden Seiten
scharf angebraten und an der Stelle gibt
jetzt etwas Gemüsebrühe in heißes Wasser
am liebsten kochen das Wasser dann kommt
das jetzt hier rein
so
Deckel drauf Hitze runterschalten auf
die mittlere Stufe und jetzt wartet ihr
15 bis 20 Minuten
[Musik]
so wir nutzen mal wieder die
Zwischenzeit und machen die unfassbar
leckere white source Leute ich bin ich
dran denke oh ich könnte mich so
reinlegen das war wirklich super lecker
und diese white Source ist auch extrem
bekannt und ich verrate euch jetzt
Geheimnis in nehmt euch einfach nur
Joghurt ich nehme hier 3,5%igen
darunter würde ich nicht gehen also 1,5
oder 0,1 das macht dann wieder zu
wässrig so dann haben wir hier
Mayonnaise das muss sein
da kommt jetzt natürlich Knoblauch rein
dieser Knoblauchgeschmack war schon so
richtig intensiv so eine große
Knoblauchzehe ihr könnt übrigens den New
York food Block euch anschauen ich
verlinke ihn euch am Ende dieses Videos
und in die Infobox und dann könnt ihr
mal abchecken was für Fußboden wir da
alles noch entdeckt haben da haben wir
süße herzhafte Sports alles mögliche
haben und zwar 24 Stunden lang durch
ganz New York probiert so und dann nehme
ich jetzt noch Salz Pfeffer dann nehme
ich auch wieder Pfeffer aus der Mühle
hat einfach ganz anders als bereits
gemahlene Fässer so und jetzt schmecken
wir eigentlich nur noch ab aber haha ich
bin ja am Fasten deshalb abschmecken
darf man zwar aber wenn es nicht
unbedingt sein muss lassen
aber wenn ihr die Möglichkeit schmeckt
Abschnitten Saft nun ein bisschen
okay es kann auf einmal ganz viel
aber ich denke das reicht ich denke das
passt so das verrühre ich jetzt und dann
auch noch ganz typisch ist Petersilie
habe ich hier schon fein gehackt kommt
noch mit rein und jetzt werdet ihr euch
wundern aber vertraut mir ein bisschen
Puderzucker nur ein bisschen weil die
süße passt einfach perfekt zu dieser
Soße wir können den Puderzucker auch
sieben wenn ihr dicke Klümpchen drin
habt aber das löst sich jetzt hier
gleich sowieso auf und dann ist die
Walze ist auch schon fertig Leute dann
warten wir jetzt eigentlich nur noch auf
den Reis auf unser Hähnchen das wird
dann noch zerrupft und dann können wir
servieren
[Musik]
so wir sind soweit wir können Anrichten
das schöne ist wenn ihr das Hähnchen
zerrupft dann saugt es noch mal so die
Gemüsebrühe auf und beim quasi
verschwindet schon die ganze Gemüsebrühe
auch noch mal im Hähnchen also haben wir
die geballte Ladung hier Gewürze und ach
finde ich ich rieche schon es riecht
eins zu eins wie in New York als wir vor
diesem Truck standen haben sie hat sich
noch mit dem Arbeiter unterhalten und äh
ja ja war einfach eine schöne Zeit ich
werde euch jetzt noch mal so ein
Serviervorschlag machen so wie es auch
dort war dort gab es nämlich auch ähm
frische Tomaten und Eisbergsalat klein
geschnippelt dazu die Tomaten könnt ihr
Salzen genau den Salat lasse ich jetzt
so und jetzt nehme ich mir erstmal den
Reis der ist auch richtig schön locker
geworden schöne Farbe gebe ich hier an
eine Ecke den Reis
die Zeit bereits Körner hebe ich jetzt
hier noch auf nichts verschwenden so
ruhig ein bisschen mehr die gab es auch
ganz typisch und dort für dort
traditionell in so Alu Containern wenn
ihr persönlich jetzt nicht so schön aber
mein Gott das ist halt street food
da geht es halt vielleicht geht's auch
anders aber ich denke es sind auch
Kostengründe so jetzt einmal dieses Pult
schicken oh sieht so gut aus direkt
daneben da auch nicht geizen also die
hatten auch schon ordentliche Portion
muss ich sagen und es war auch echt
günstig ich werde mal recherchieren in
meiner Galerie das ist gekostet hat und
dann werde ich euch da mal die portions
den portions-preis ein so und jetzt da
geht's einfach mit dem sauberen hinten
dran hier noch Salat Tomaten und was
ganz ganz typisch ist ist libanesisches
bzw arabisches Fladenbrot in so Dreiecke
geschnitten das könnt ihr einfach mit
dazu servieren je frischer desto besser
natürlich
so und dann gibt es noch eine scharfe
Soße da könnt ihr zum Beispiel einfach
so ein scharfesoße nehmen ich persönlich
mag es ja nicht so scharf aber die White
Source und jetzt nennt mich pingelig
aber die haben wir so Squeezer dort und
ich fühle mir das jetzt einfach einen
Spritzbeutel damit ich dann auch so
richtig schöne Linien darauf zaubern
kann mich so drauf gehen würde dann
würde es so klecksartig darauf verteilt
werden und ich finde das Auge ist mit
übrigens seht ihr den test test bei uns
am Iftar Tisch also beim Fastenbrechen
und dann könnt ihr euch ehrliche Meinung
abholen ich bin sehr gespannt ich muss
sagen haben sie ein extrem großer
Kritiker und ich bin einfach gespannt ob
es ihm genauso gut schmeckt wie ja dort
in New York
[Musik]
tasty teste
dich zu lange hier quatschen aber es
sieht auf jeden Fall eins aus wie bei
karl-geist und auch cool
mega ich muss sagen ich muss gleich auch
erstmal probieren aber ich habe es ja
ausprobiert gerade
so in New York diese chaotischen Stadt
und habe dann dieses Gefühl wieder von
hargeis und Spaß echt perfekt dann habe
ich gesagt
also ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
schwer jetzt nehmen die Rezeptur aber
ist schmeckt auf jeden Fall
Joghurt Knobi gemischlinge lecker und
Hähnchen sehr zart ich liebe dieses ich
liebe das
ich mag das überhaupt
nach und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten Mal
haben die nur Tomaten und Eisbergsalat
auf jeden Fall Leute sehr lecker
nachmachen glaub mir und alle die jetzt
mal gegessen haben die wissen jetzt ganz
genau was ich meine also Leute tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]